[Musica]
e per l'ufficializzazione cozzi nuova
challenge che ci avete consigliato voi
giorno fa un post su youtube community
nell'attacco migliori tv ho chiesto di
consigliarmi qualche video da fare
quelli con più la legge quelli che mi
piacevano di più li avremmo fatti li
darà al sera descrive panettone ciale
dice come la pizza ciale insomma con il
[ __ ] slash pandoro e invece non lo
stridore come abbiamo già fatto la torta
al challenge la bit challenger la
pancake challenge con la ruota cosa non
mi ha detto di fare la panda challenge
contro panettone challenge perché c'è da
sempre questo dibattito quindi scrivete
nei commenti se questi tetti un pandoro
o film panettone sono statue l'altra
vagno dotta state ovviamente insomma
straniero 315 tv faceva vitale pensi
stimolo mia mente
io ho preferito il pandoro e panettone
al cioccolato eccola falsi panettoni
sì insomma la rimando tutte e due però
con le domande sono il panettone sistema
ma imparare buonissimo però aver sparato
al parti uguali
secondo la jaguar da una parola va ai
canditi queste a me non piace il pari
stato perché non vi piacciono i candidi
e i pezzetti di koto semmai forte che se
andremo a girare la ruota
e evidente si capita dovremmo metterlo
nel pallone nel panettone faremo vari
strati come la torta challenge e alla
fine andremo a mangiarlo sperando che
questi ingredienti si stanno tutti
assieme con il vino un po cosa ci capita
alla fine del video potrete votare se
vinco io se vince in vitale di mettere
il sondaggio maker ingaggiare uno su
base agli ingredienti ci sono cioè
quello che mi piacerebbe più mangiare
siamo primi ma devo dire che il mio
bellissimo libro ascoltato so se lo
volete ricevere appunto come regalo di
natale
vi lascio il link in descrizione se ce
l'avete già fatto sapere nei commenti
iniziamo subito vediamo chi inizia dall
inizio abbiamo già tagliati bari tra
liti
vediamo un po che cosa spero di no
[Musica]
così di cioccolato e cioccolato limone
in alcuni casi sta bene altrimenti
limone fanta iniziamo bene benissimo
dire ok allora un primo strato grafica
allora io lo voglio mettere a fette lo
metto premuto succo di limone beh perché
non diventi di superarsi montanaro
limone si sta bene secondo me sì dipende
dagli altri ingredienti che mette top
infatti prima che bagnatissima della
spallata devo un profumo di limone
particolare lo abbiamo fatto lo metto
così così
[Musica]
io l'ho sognata da montella ovviamente
della crema di nocciole non è un ultimo
19 non esagerare
questo non è giusto
altre curva orecchiuto anzi ci vuole
ancora un altro po di nutella che non va
bene non si collega in tanti se e tanti
ma mi sento fortunato valentia
altro che il limone abello l'oreal
amiamo lo strano che ortona timore
secondo strano vedere non equa pieno di
canditi
eppure la lanciò i colori stava
capitando 6 e l'altro è stata giudicata
troppo giovane
invece sono capitati i colori allora
come l'altra volta come una torta
talenti come i colori siano 4 anche
verde si dovrà chiudere gli occhi e
bicchiere e dovrò per scarico allora sì
come l'altra volta mi avete detto che ho
messo il verde troppo in mezzo
via allora io ti metto qui così sono qui
sono tutti a 4 qui quindi quale sceglie
no non devi sentire da voi anche se tira
però a questo sarà allora posso decorare
il mio panda aumentando tutto il succo
del limone sceso giù che l'occhio
attacca sono kiri babbo natale facendo
mozione popolari questo è il naso ma sta
benissimo e la bocca
ma lo metta la barba per portare sentito
male di me questa è la barba non si sta
tutta quindi rimane qua poi la forza
oddio sembrava babbo natale malefico
stiamo lavorando il fratello si capisce
dopo aver fatto un lungo perché è un po
il pan pan non faccio la pupilla sono
sempre troppo malefico come traccia
babbo natale mm e come li se gli
allunghi si dice la bianchi o lunghi che
allora è affatto un bel caschetto può
notare alla moda allora come vi sembra
di bergamo no la vediamo faccia i bordi
tipo in questione la mia decorazioni
natalizie brutta però può divertire la
divertente parrocchia
ma allora esiste una banana secondo me
possiamo modello stonata è perfetto
spero che riesca gli muore in amore dove
limone limone o la passava amore camera
errori chi di yakin
voglio proprio vedere che disegni lo
farai stessa cosa avrebbe da femmina
perché senza guardare sono qua sono
quattro sì ok dai 1 giugno sono già al
lavoro italiane allora cosa disegno
disegniamo la renna e non dopo la
diretta è un po difficile da fermare
allora vediamo un po di sensibilità e
quindi tu vorresti disattivare non
arrendersi certo questa è la renna a si
verifica a vedere una renda ha spiegato
ancora non è pronta a ha tra l'altro
viene più male comunque nel panettone
perché si sono i buchi in più ci sono
tutti i canditi
ma siccome io sono un bravo disegno come
l'avete vista la challenge in cui
abbiamo disegnato io e vitale con la
ruota le penitenze stato troppo e
divertente dovevamo disegnare con la
bocca disegnare occhi chiusi ero troppo
bello e poteva vederlo poi dopo questo
video che la cosa la tua zampe di dietro
le due zampe davanti la testa con la
bocca
delle corna fida e carina ma prima
ancora il più grande delle zampe perché
c'è una cosa di volpe poi li mettiamo
pure quel cielo stellato
capita che stella e questo è una stella
cadente elite e completato il secondo
strato è fatto l'ultimo entrato no terzo
strato di medu mare qualcosa di carino
come scritto anche di capi siano poi
nello strato somme praxis perché poi
sopra faremo due giri di ruota io spero
di capsico nutella zucchero a velo
questo quesito per farci una bella sopra
però va bene sono capitati adesso
andiamo a mettere gli spring su quale
sceglie allora sono rose e fiori
dimentichi ci sono sì che carini ho
capito che mi sono una piaga avviene di
fare allora speriamo le mie qualcosa di
buono la banana
[Musica]
uno scempio che veramente si ripeterà le
ferme
allora che comandante loro giorno messo
al piano di sotto io qui vedo che si
sono delle berline di cioccolato
quindi io ammette lei questo è quanto
viene di cioccolato
[Musica]
non esagerare o no da mettono i buchi
così almeno prima veroli basano su che
cadono subiamo tanti mister il vento
basta guarda che ha un profumo che
bortolato cioccolato cioccolato
contenute in un ottimo motore ferma
ultimo strato te lo devo chiudere lo
strato adesso riesce con peperoncino
allora siamo arrivati alla fine dei
distratti possiamo girare la ruota due
volte a testa per ricoprire la fine ecco
lì andremo montarlo quindi speriamo che
capiti qualcosa di intelligente
[Musica]
c'era un pò la geron e annienta come
esisterà allora lo sviluppo da zero se
avete mai mangiato ico anche saprete
cosa è che sapore a me piace tantissimo
nei pancakes male rimando non ho mai
provato molto più realtà non me lo
rovina siamo tra l'altro costa
tantissimo lo sviluppo da zero
e mettermi troppo sta accadendo per un
bellissimo effetto bello ma vi sembra il
sapore di un mega pancakes gigante del
mio primo strato definitivo maledice
calmato un po di questi ve devo
concentrare scelgo io non ho modo di
zucchero lo so che non certo molto ma in
casa tenta campania 3 per cosa posso
mettere lo sciroppo taglio non mio
questa gara in meno
metti il limone che ci posso mettere la
modello no basta è è putroppo pieno
strano vedere un panettone bianco sembra
che abbia nevicato stola me parlamentare
da bertone cellino
insomma di un po strano ma sì meglio
questo che lo sciroppo d'acero no quello
che voi l'ultima la grappa
giorno 1 maggio tutto tutto tutto tutto
intero non lo so bene cosa speri che è
stata tolta ci credo ho visto io
perfetto tiro parato
allora io ci metterei le gocce di
cioccolato
la modella la banana e forse un limone
da man o questi coloranti prima solo
sopra oppure lo zucchero a velo
ma il pandoro lo zucchero 0 metterei
perché classico pandoro zucchero a velo
panettone nel vicino trentino
penso che a meno che non avremo altra
scelta
scusa se devo scegliere io scelgo quello
che si sta meglio allora vista che
sionisti lo zucchero meno chio
a passare la campbell ha messo prima
questo è il mio panettone
come potete vedere e di una perfezione
fai vedere i vari strati e tutto storto
i vari strati allora sotto che non si
apre abbiamo la lanterna di nocciola qui
abbiamo il colorante renna e io sembro
maionese o mostarda crema colorata e
quella è l'ultimo infilzato e ultimo
strato che ricopre tutto lo zucchero
ovvero poco non troppo perché sennò ti
affoghi chi non è rimasto affogato
mangiando il pandoro invece ci hanno
messo poco così è perfetto e contento
perche che si mangia troppo troppo
bistrattata
io io io ho fatto vedere nel frattempo
non posso mangiare
da allora ecco il mio molto più bello a
parole ovviamente non so se sarà più
buono poi allora primo strato abbiamo il
limone non si vede mai
si vede che romagna tozzi paura di
averne per tutto robo poi secondo strato
abbiamo babbo natale e inquietante è
rimasta la faccia a faccia poi terzo
strato abbiamo di spicco la serrata e
blu che carini e per finire con
confidiamo con il lo sciroppo e come si
chiama la piccola tutto giovani siamo
pronti all'assalto e capitale ovviamente
in fitto allora dobbiamo mangiare una
fetta vero allora schifo
prendi una festa è più o meno così no
credo ha detto di no
pechino e poi torniamo un affetto a metà
un panettone ma sembra normale ma solo
cosa ho staccato un costone si stima
della terra queste di cioccolato
prodotto da iniziato ad associare
insieme allora non lo posso mangiare un
po per mangiarlo tutto va bene così
penso che prima di tutto in bocca guarda
becco è indotto il dopo buon con le
pozze di cioccolato con velo buonismo e
devi anche il peggiore quello di
colorante giallo mostarda piazza in moto
dobbiamo usare un big mach banking
limita le mando per tre ore
non serve capace di non fermarsi per tre
ore di fila
quando non sapere nei commenti sono
volete trovato quindi che voto ti dai
trovato un panettone lo sai che non è
niente male direi un 8 e mezzo caspita
peccato per il colorante sarebbe stato
meglio nutella adesso io lo devo
nascondere perché evitare se non mangerà
tutto che è arrivato il mio momento
dell'ostaggio
anzi aiuto abito tagliarlo va bene non
vuol dire solo che mangia tutto no pezzo
si no questa è detto sia ormai al
coltello sotto lo zero o calcolato equa
è rimasto normale dal assaggiamo come di
sprinkles
il frigo sono croccanti il colorante
molto dolce ma se vediamo il limone come
mimo nel superare devo dire che ci sta
bene non è male devo provare la parte di
sopra detto che mi sta accadendo tutto
lo sciroppo d'acero lo zucchero destano
bejing come mostre funzione indotto su
un muro sequestrato un buono ma domani 1
maggio bard ao tuo basta molto buono ma
un po più monotoni sorpreso perché il
limone ci sta bene nel mondo del mio
primo post non poter marta allo stato
sono al meglio vuoi mangiare non lo
credo nell'uomo limone ha mai un
pezzettino piccolo nicolò perché con
limone o la somma ed è piccolissimo
problema è un altro proverai ce relativa
al rilascio poi sondaggio scrivete ti
ami perde 6 vinti vita ora l'aspetto
alla descrizione dei sapori se vinco io
me lo posso vendere tutto ma se vince
anita invece mimando il fondo dopo pazza
potete sapere nei parlamenti il times of
del momento che è se siete team pandoro
o team panettone lascia un po a quattro
cartellini e su cui cliccare per vedere
i nostri altri video le nostre altre
challenge i nostri zaino video
divertenti cliccate su quello che
preferite
[Musica]